Whether it's the devilish new characters,
cryptic answers to ancient prophecies,
or giant worms, the trailer for Dune: Part Two
is full of details that you might've missed.
It can be argued that the parent-child
relationship between Lady Jessica and Paul may be
one of the most dynamic in science-fiction. Dune
author Frank Herbert's characterization of Lady
Jessica is nuanced, with her motives to conceive
Paul being her desperate love of Duke Leto
Atreides and her personal desire to bring about
the Kwisatz Haderach — the universe's super being.
But as close as she and Paul are in the first
film, the cracks begin to show when Paul realizes
how his Bene Gesserit lineage has affected him.
He still has a long way to go before achieving
his destiny, but the closer he gets, the more it
pushes him away from those who can understand him.
Though Paul seems to believe that he
must cling to his father's principles,
he's already slipping. His visions have shown
him that he will start a intergalactic holy war,
and with Duke Leto not believing in revenge,
it's fair to say he wouldn't approve of the
genocide that Paul is seemingly destined
to cause. This brings Paul inner turmoil
as he doesn't want to be capable of these
unspeakable acts — but Jessica continues
to push him, all while he starts
pulling away from her influence.
"We gave them something to hope for."
"That's not hope!"
In the Dune: Part Two trailer, we see Lady
Jessica gasping for air and opening her eyes,
now the vibrant blue of the Fremen. This
color change usually indicates prolonged
exposure to Spice — an addictive psychoactive
substance found only on the planet Arrakis,
considered the most valuable
substance in the universe. However,
the blood crusting Jessica's nose hints at
a very specific source for her blue eyes.
It's likely that this scene is part of a "spice
agony" — a ritual in which members of the Bene
Gesserit voluntarily ingest a poison known
as the Water of Life — liquid harvested from
sandworms that die from drowning. Although the
Water of Life is fatal even in small quantities,
high-ranking members of the sisterhood
are able to transform the substance into
a benign liquid with their mental powers. This
incredibly painful transformation unlocks a new
level of power within those who survive,
transforming them into a Reverend Mother.
There's even a possible glimpse of the Water
of Life a few seconds earlier in the trailer,
held in a glass vial by a cloaked figure.
Jessica's spice agony will probably play
a major part in her story throughout Dune: Part
Two, and this is most likely our first glimpse.
Princess Irulan is the eldest daughter
of the emperor of the known universe.
But more importantly, anyone familiar
with the Dune saga will also be familiar
with Irulan's work as a historian,
with Herbert beginning a significant
number of chapters with an epigraph
from Irulan's professional writings.
Typically, the passage will frame a notable
historical event as it officially happened,
and then the subsequent chapter will depict that
same event as it actually happened. In this way,
Irulan remains a consistent, prevalent force
in Dune without really being present for all of
the events of the story, not even physically
appearing in the first book until the end.
While the Warner Bros. film mirrors this by
having Florence Pugh's princess making her
debut in Dune Part Two, it also seems
that her role has been expanded upon.
The Irulan in the first book did as she was
told and nothing more — a passive participant
in her own life — though what she does later in
the series is another story entirely. However,
the movie version of Irulan seems to be
actively asking questions and seeking
answers. We can guess that director Denis
Villeneuve is planning to tie Irulan more
closely into the main plot, or he might
be setting her up for future story arcs.
Either way, it's safe to say
that no one in their right
mind would cast Pugh in this part
and not let her explore the space.
The longest section of the Dune: Part
Two trailer teases Paul's first ride on
a sandworm. He places a thumper
in the sand and readies for the
massive creature's arrival. Over the
montage, we can hear Zendaya's Chani:
"Have you ever had a dream about your first ride?"
This question is likely more somber
than it initially seems. In the novel,
by the time Paul experiences his first sandworm
ride, he's had many visions of the future,
and they're not all hopeful. In this scene,
Chani is asking if he's foreseen how his
first ride will go, and whether or not he will
survive. Paul is a bit nervous to ride the worm,
and he knows that he's much older than most
Fremen when they do so for the first time. Also,
the continued trailer dialogue
by Javier Bardem's Stilgar,
advising Paul how to ride Shai-Hulud, is also
pulled — nearly word for word — out of the book.
The Dune: Part Two trailer shows us Feyd-Rautha
Harkonnen — played by Austin Butler — in all
his bald, treacherous glory. The great
foil to Paul Atreides in the Dune novel,
Feyd is the nephew and intended successor of Baron
Vladimir Harkonnen — played on screen
in Dune: Part One by Stellan Skarsgård.
Feyd bears the same drab, reptilian look as
the rest of his vicious family, with most
of his moments in the trailer shot in complete
black-and-white. We see him participating in the
gladiatorial arenas on Giedi Prime — the Harkonnen
homeworld glimpsed briefly in the first film. We
also see an interaction with the Bene Gesserit,
Lady Margot Fenring — played by Léa Seydoux.
Finally, we see what appears to be a
shot of Feyd facing off against Paul,
with Paul uttering the famous Fremen challenge,
"May thy knife chip and shatter."
We won't spoil it here, but if
you've already read the book,
you know exactly what this moment leads to.
The trailer gives audience members their
very first glimpse at Lady Margot. Though
she becomes a major character later in
the Dune book series, it seems her part
in Villeneuve's film may have been expanded
from her original role in the first novel.
Margot is a member of the Bene Gesserit — the
powerful matriarchal order who are partially
responsible for the destruction of House Atreides
on Arrakis. They've spent centuries orchestrating
a selective breeding program to cross bloodlines
of the universe's noble houses, and hope to
mate Margot with Feyd-Rautha Harkonnen. This
will give the secret organization a leg up,
as they'll have a member of House
Harkonnen fully in their control,
doubling the amount of power in their possession.
Book fans know that Margot's fate
and Paul's are closely intertwined,
and that ultimately Paul's rise will precipitate
Margot's fall. But, of course, this adaptation
of Dune might switch things around a bit. For
now, it's clear that Margot is here to stay.
House Harkonnen has been a shadow on House
Atreides from the opening moments of Dune:
Part One, but if you thought the Baron was bad,
just wait for Feyd. Villeneuve told Vanity Fair,
"Austin Butler brought to the screen something
that would be a cross between a psychotic,
sociopath serial killer and Mick Jagger."
This features briefly in the
trailer as Feyd duels in an arena,
observed by Lady Margot. As we've said, the
connection between the noble psychopath and
the Bene Gesserit is significant. Established
in the first film, the Bene Gesserit are intent
on bringing about the Kwisatz Haderach
through centuries of meticulous breeding.
"You were told to bear only daughters. But you,
and your pride, thought you could
produce the Kwisatz Haderach."
Had Jessica given birth to a girl, as was
originally planned, the child would have
eventually wed Feyd in a political marriage,
with their offspring likely being the Kwisatz
Haderach. Now Paul is rising as the messiah of
Arrakis, cutting out the Harkonnens completely.
But the Bene Gesserit don't appear to be
giving up on the Harkonnens quite yet.
The planet of Arrakis is foreboding and
hostile, even for those who possess the
technology to travel among the stars. The
desert planet requires specialized skills
and knowledge for someone to be able to survive.
Although the planetary colonists of ruling noble
houses struggle to cultivate Spice, the Fremen —
Arrakis' indigenous population — are well adapted,
utilizing several novel technologies
that allow their people to flourish.
"Thank you for the stillsuits."
"They are of Fremen make. The best."
Among their most notable items are Maker Hooks
— featured prominently throughout the Dune:
Part Two trailer. These hooks allow the
Fremen to mount and steer the giant sandworms,
and even though Paul is told not to
show off during his first ride attempt,
he's clearly quite good at it. Maker Hooks are
important within Fremen culture because riding
a sandworm is a rite of passage into adulthood.
Fremen are able to use Maker Hooks to steer a
sandworm by hooking into gaps in the sandworm's
plating, forcing the creatures to instinctively
move in the opposite direction. Even though
it looks like Paul is having fun in the Dune:
Part Two trailer, this action means much more
than possessing a skill in the eyes of the Fremen.
Dune: Part Two will feature many characters
on the hunt for Paul Atreides. As Princess
Irulan's voiceover questions his
fate after the Harkonnen attack,
we get a glimpse of Josh Brolin's Gurney Halleck
looking through a pair of binoculars. The editors
have snuck in some clever imagery here,
since much of Gurney's story in the sequel
will revolve around finding Paul and getting
revenge on someone he thought he could trust.
Even before the Harkonnen attack, Duke Leto knew
there was a traitor embedded in House Atreides.
In the novel, he even momentarily believed Jessica
could be the culprit — given her status as a Bene
Gesserit — and Gurney is likewise suspicious.
Although audiences know Chang Chen's Dr. Yueh
was the traitor, Gurney hasn't learned that
information, and has continued to believe that
Lady Jessica aided the Harkonnens. When we pick
up with him in Dune: Part Two, he's one of the
few survivors of the original attack, searching
Arrakis for Paul, and vowing revenge on Jessica.
While Gurney didn't have much to do in Dune:
Part One, he still plays a significant
role as one of Paul's major allies.
Once the door to Paul's potential opens, it cannot
be closed. His visions start simply at first,
with nightly dreams of Chani, whom he has yet to
meet. But more and more, his mind opens thanks
to the Spice, and soon he knows many things that
he wishes he didn't. As his destiny is revealed,
so is his mother's fate. Before Jessica
even confirms that she's pregnant in Dune:
Part One, Paul tells her of the
baby she will have. In his mind,
he sees Jessica's blue-within-blue eyes
and her future facial tattoos. Though
we can't definitively say what the tattoos mean,
we can give a pretty accurate guess. Jessica
has built her life around the Bene Gesserit and
fulfilling the prophecy of the Kwisatz Haderach.
"A mind — powerful enough
to bridge space and time."
Villeneuve told Vanity Fair,
"Lady Jessica is one of the masterminds
of Dune. She's trying to play her own
agenda. The meaning of that look
would be unveiled in Part Two."
It seems just as Paul comes to terms with his
place in the universe, so too does Jessica.
There are many mysterious forces in play
throughout the galaxy depicted in Dune.
Paul is the product of a long line of genetic
manipulation for the express purpose of creating
a superhuman capable of leading humanity into a
universal golden age. This Bene Gesserit breeding
program cultivates each successive generation to
possess greater acumen with their mental powers.
One of the most notable powers
is known as "The Voice." This
skill is prominently seen — and heard — in Dune:
Part One when Jessica and Paul escape their
assassination attempt during the Harkonnen coup.
"Remove her gag."
The power essentially allows its practitioners
to mentally dominate most individuals. In the
final moments of the Dune: Part Two trailer,
Paul is addressing an assembly of Fremen.
Although the music swells, one can hear some
hint of The Voice's distinct auditory cue,
maybe implying that Paul uses The
Voice to rally the Fremen to his cause.